[Music]
and is that racist news it's always
racist
you ask that how it was submitted by
Anna from Flo Rida Oh
a Detroit firefighter was fired after
taking a watermelon to a fire station
what I heard about this was it was it
like white races was for Black History
Month or something and if February it
was a white firefighter that just got
hired on right and then he found out
that that's a predominantly black
firehouse so you bought a watermelon to
the black firehouse but if it's during
the summer watermelon is in season and
it's the best so I don't know what the
problem is
well I didn't see reports like he found
out that it was like that it was
intentional they're saying that they
don't score incidental yeah I mean I
don't know so there's a story so 41 year
old Robert Pattinson so he is a new a
probation probationary firefighter so he
had just gotten hired to this particular
firehouse and so he decided to take a
watermelon wrapped in a pink ribbon to
make the other like his fellow
firefighters I'm a pink ribbon that's I
made it worse and it's a really weird
present it is with the Pew yeah you
[ __ ] up there apparently this
firehouse it's 90% african-american
firefighters and so they're saying that
there were a lot of firefighters that
did get offended and just coming down
the pole yeah because they're saying
that this whole like bearing gifts it's
not mandatory it's voluntary but it's
usually like it's a tradition for
firefighters like when the new guy comes
to give gifts and usually it's doughnuts
but you are a lot of farmers like
doughnuts too apparently who doesn't
like doughnut tree who started the
stereotype that black people like martyr
melon cook I think everybody likes
watermelon yeah like watermelon you're
obviously a rapist like that's how it
kind of works right like watermelon
watermelon URI
who the [ __ ] hates watermelon I don't
know anybody who has well aside from the
fact that they have a melon allergy but
I
I love watermelon yeah the top was he
trying to be written it like did he cut
it open and there was fried chicken
inside the bunny it was a white
firefighters are pissed - yeah the black
is my hell yeah I love this watermelon
isn't it racist to assume that someone's
being racist yeah that means there's a
racist mind in there somewhere because
unless here's like he had a letter and
it's like I know how much black people
love watermelon so here here's your your
favorite being in the water because it's
coming from a white guy yeah and also
wall I mean okay so but then even if it
was that like if a white guy brought
sushi or [ __ ] orange chicken to a
predominantly Asian company I just see
it as he's ignorant but he's trying his
best to connect but even that that's
different because there's a clear
cultural tied to that watermelon is just
the [ __ ] fruit that everybody likes
he's neutral dude you want to talk about
fried chicken and watermelon go to any
[ __ ] Korean birthday party every
[ __ ] time so I never knew never
understood who started that stereotype
that black people only liked that [ __ ]
cuz I got offended cuz Korean people
like that [ __ ] I thought my people
invented Fried Chicken today I thought
that's that I thought that's why they
there's that wealth in addiction oh
maybe maybe we're just ignorant to the
history and the racism Oh Scottish
people might say yeah I see because I
just pictured southern you know black
people that made up like barbecue and
fried chicken and all that stuff because
I want to know who made this stereotype
because for me I'm okay with the
stereotype if they said to me like hey
your people like fried chicken a lot
remember like exactly some deep ass
history that we don't know about I got
to know who started this [ __ ] and we're
from California - so it's like far away
from all you
yeah that's right yeah so anyways back
to this whole thing so then um they're
saying that certain firefighters like
its fellow firefighters to get offended
and that it was racially insensitive to
bring watermelon into a firehouse
you know what the equivalent might be is
if someone brought roasted dog to our
company at a supermarket it is it by
itself it's a neutral thing that exists
yes like chicken feet that's already
like culturally biased you have to bring
like a pomegranate you have to bring a
persimmon like something that is already
neutral by itself and its brand in a
certain way yeah
so that watermelon exist in agency
everywhere yeah that's true everybody
does the yeah everybody that's just not
like chicken feet unless he was like he
came in and he was like I know you
people like this yeah I need to hear
that statement look he said so Robert is
saying that he it was not a joke he did
not mean to offend anyone I like
watermelon yeah so that's what he's
saying but apparently there is a zero
tolerance for discriminatory behavior
inside the dfd the Detroit Fire
Department and so because of this after
an investigation he it was determined
that the best course of action was to
let him go everyone off even though he
didn't mean to do it yeah yeah so you
should you know like I always bring
watermelon to barbecue watermelon so
what if that guy was just bringing it
cuz I would put my foot down as I listen
I [ __ ] like watermelon you don't have
to have any well I'm eating it then like
what the [ __ ] where maybe he was
thinking like if he wasn't trying to you
know make a joke or whatever he may be
thinking like Oh firefighters we're all
trying to keep our body's nice and
fitted maybe something healthier than
donut watermelon fruits should have
brought a bunch of grapefruit or
something you know what maybe yeah so
like what if he brought watermelon
cantaloupe like a basket full of fruits
that might be very different the whole
watermelon
oh what the bowl like what's the point
of putting a bug was he trying to be
funny with pee yeah so it could be
interpreted kind of like what's up what
is this I think it's really hard to
defend and especially in the climate
right now because like a lot of people
won't tolerate the climate is what I'm
saying like that's that's irrelevant
that's completely [ __ ] irrelevant I
think like it might be insensitive no
it's not even insensitive it's the
[ __ ] fruit is what I'm saying
how do you explain the thing broad
ribbon because normally they come with
doughnuts so maybe the joke was I'm
bringing a [ __ ] watermelon but then
but then given like what Julie is saying
is just given like you know everything
that's been happening and this the
stigma that's tied to it and I don't
agree with that if he was racist why
would he want to work at a 95 it doesn't
make any sense does he pick where he
wants to work apply that you apply the
partner work I like hated Indians or
whatever right I'm not gonna go out of
my way to work out a curry restaurant
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
you know like so for me like once again
you have to there has to be a background
see he became in and he was like you
people like it then yeah I get it but
maybe for me as somebody who's every
single potluck somebody brought [ __ ]
watermelon so it's not like a racial day
it's just a [ __ ] fruit to me yeah so
then after this whole controversy thing
came out I love the photo dude you know
so there was this Facebook post by trade
arias so he said I'm sure some people
heard about the firefighter and the
watermelon incident on the news just
want to let everyone know he's a real
amazing dude and it was all good
intentions and our entire class
supporting him in this especially us
african-americans and that's all that
needs to be said stay up brother
so people are supporting the white guy
yeah so all these guys are supporting
the white guy that took the watermelon
that's what I'm saying
see oh oh they were the graduating class
and then he got into that firehouse
where it's just you know trying to break
the ice with new people
yeah then this guy is saying it was with
all good intentions and he's a really
great guy I mean if there's other
firefighters that are african-american
that do support this then but you don't
even need that is what I'm saying
yeah when I heard this story it
immediately just sounded like that's
kind of racist to assume that that's
racist that's what I feel like it's the
white guy of the firehouse that actually
got pissed the white guy that's trying
to control the other like the reverse
Gil or whatever and I feel like in that
fire group maybe it was that like I got
really mad and then I would be the black
dude that's already eating the
watermelon
oh we're mad is that local to do like my
bad you know not supposed to eat this
yeah so like a white guy comes and wants
to break the ice and has a tray of sushi
and then the other white guy gets mad
sushi you know I like sushi it's like
everybody needs like a racial ambassador
now you don't know why this it's already
causing divided lines with people I
[ __ ] hate that it's like one like
when we go out to eat and there's like
this one white guy in the group is I oh
do you guys eat this just eat it don't
ask me okay just [ __ ] eat it bro you
don't need my approval to use chopsticks
just [ __ ] do it maybe they just got a
walk on eggshells now because they don't
want to look like they're a part of the
you know the alt-right crew or whatever
they don't want to be mixed in with
those guys it's just everybody yeah
they're just walking on eggshells
it's like hypersensitivity I mean just
just stay away from the general no nose
of things you know what I mean
I don't assume that people eat dog or
[ __ ] or you know like you know there are
also a lot of rage like raging Asians to
that pit get pissed off and like take
out their [ __ ] dirty Chinese
restaurant game game down completely I
mean you guys didn't have an issue but
apparently it was a big enough issue to
shut it down oh we don't we don't all
agree obviously so it's hard to kind of
you I think I can see how people will
always walk on eggshells because you
don't know if one ambassador of that
ethnicity is gonna agree with
the other yeah I might be cool with the
with the ain't like with the dirty
Chinese game right but let's say Dave is
not cool with it who do you listen to
yeah we both are right you know have
have the right to our opinions but none
of us represent all of Asian America but
that's why we should also like really
pay attention to intent intent is very
important because intent it also allows
something to be very forgivable you know
cuz there's endurance which is just
somebody being stupid and then there's
good intent behind it and you just have
to be corrective in that sense you don't
mean because I've had a lot of
situations where people were offensive
but they weren't trying to be and you
still know you're lightweight a little
defensive man like oh why because of
this isn't that so I'm cool with that
you know and that's the problem with a
lot of comedy to like people feel like
everybody has to BBC comedy that was
never PC in the first place we're
supposed to stir [ __ ] up an attempt
behind a word also gives it power or not
so that's the weird thing to me that's
just a [ __ ] fruit well have you heard
of that story where Casey was trying to
order coffee and then the guy so he
ordered a black coffee and then the guy
at the drive-thru he was like oh here's
your coffee with no cream no shirt and
he was like yeah black coffee he's like
oh I can't say that anymore because
there was a customer that got really
offended because I called this coffee
black coffee and it was an African
American guy [ __ ] that guy you [ __ ]
sensitive [ __ ] it's that coffee
it's literally black coffee well he well
I order black coffee at McDonald's and
they also call it no cream no sugar
and then they explained to me it's
because it could be confusing because
sometimes black coffee also contains
sugar in it so for them it's just easier
to just express it this is the me name
there's no creamer no sugar so for me
from that standpoint I completely
understand you know what a mix-up order
where someone gets black coffee with
sugar and one is black coffee
unsweetened and then you give the wrong
person the wrong thing is explanation
that was specifically because someone
got offended over the word black oh so
does he get offended by everything like
blackjack what you mean blackjack it's
just 21 yeah like you know like
everything black I mean that's how crazy
like nobody will take a stand on
anything you know what I mean it was
like for example that dove commercial
you just got done not that dove had was
so stupid so the Dove ad showed this
black woman right she takes off her
shirt she turns into a white girl
then the white rotors
to a Mexican girl so it was to show that
the soap was made for everybody skin
type but the owners on order yeah but
they only show but it would have been
worse if it was black Mexican white
because you're going lighter lighter
light oh you'd have been like black
white Mexican or something but either
way like it's clear the intent was to
show that it was for anybody of any skin
white black Mexican people will find any
reason to hate though regards that order
so in that ad people were only showing
the clip where the black girl turned
into the white girl and that was it but
they didn't show the Mexican girl that's
because people find a loominatee sign
and everything there's a triangle here
there's a triangle there they make up
their own [ __ ] stories yeah and so
like people were offended and all you
say like you're turning from somebody
dirty to something clean that wasn't it
at all that's only true when it's a
Asian commercial yeah when it was a
Chinese commercial that was also called
being racist over there yeah but then
you know at least they're open about it
they're like you know you don't want to
be dark-skinned no more be the light
skinned that's more pretty like don't
tell you straight up
but the crappy thing about that was for
for me was the commercial was fine you
know but the Dove had to put out this
like gut-wrenching apology like we are
sorry we were so no but you weren't but
they have to apologize for [ __ ] like
that you know I mean and I don't think
they should have yeah thanks for
watching guys and those are our thoughts
what are your thoughts don't forget to
comment below we want to know what you
guys are thinking but don't write
anything that will make it sad or make
us mad because after all we're just
kidding news and we're a very happy
channel for the last video click up here
[Music]